tras 24 horas de calma en las calles los
bombardeos y los combates se reanudaron
en jartum el alto el fuego acordado por
los mediadores estadounidenses y estado
10 permitió a los civiles recibir ayuda
humanitaria pero con las reservas
agotándose los residentes lucharon por
encontrar alimentos y suministros
esenciales
las tiendas siguen vacías y escasean
todo tipo de productos las tiendas de
comestibles de los alrededores hace
tiempo que se quedaron sin productos
además el hospital está cerrado y hay
una grave escasez de recursos médicos
Este es el mayor problema al que nos
enfrentamos ahora mismo
Esta es la última tregua de una serie de
intentos fallidos de detener la
violencia entre el ejército sudanesia el
grupo paramilitar fuerzas de apoyo
rápido
con Estados Unidos imponiendo sanciones
a ambos rivales el jefe del ejército App
del fatal burujana y el comandante de
las fuerzas de apoyo rápido Mohamed
handdagalu se enfrentaron por los planes
de reestructuración militar en la
transición del país a un gobierno civil
tras el derrocamiento del presidente
Omar en 2019 el conflicto estalló el 15
de abril en harton y la región
occidental del darfur desplazando a casi
dos millones de personas muchas de las
cuales han buscado refugio en países
vecinos como Egipto y Chad la ONU
Calcula que los combates han dejado 25
millones de personas en busca de ayuda
humanitaria el equivalente a más de la
mitad de la población de Sudán